what some believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believing I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves I want some of that to rub
off on to you so you can go off and
create something fantastic and amazing
get that thing inside you out into the
world and sort of help you on your
journey today we're gonna look at the
top five books or investors coming in at
number one is the Intelligent Investor
by Benjamin Graham it's really a
pleasure for me to be able to talk to
you about Ben Graham and I've had some
lucky days in my life but one of the
luckiest was in 1949 when I was 19 years
old and Lincoln Nebraska and I picked up
a copy of the intelligent industrial my
investment philosophy it really changed
my whole life I had I'd be a different
person at a different place if if I
hadn't have first seen that book I got a
bedrock of investment philosophy that
really hasn't changed ever since I read
the book I may embellish on it a little
here and there but it was Ben's ideas
that sent me down the right right path
coming at number 2 is Rich Dad Poor Dad
by Robert Kiyosaki well you have an
anniversary as well your book turns
twenty this year and has sold over 35
million copies so do the lessons that
you aim to teach I guess 20 years ago 30
years ago rather 1997 do they still
resonate today are they're more
important today than ever before because
you know back in the old days 1997
before you guys were born I wish it was
you know I said your house is not an
asset the rich don't work for money on
savers were losers and in 2000 you know
everything started to collapse and you
know
interest rates drop below zero which has
never happened before people lost their
houses lost their jobs so it's more
important today than ever before and I'm
not really saying that it's right or
wrong I'm just saying we need financial
education
what does school teach us about money
answers nothing
coming in at number 3 is flash boys a
Wall Street revolt by Michael Lewis this
week there is a lot of buzz about a
provocative new book focusing on how it
has changed and how one thousandth of a
second can make a big difference the
book is titled flash boys the author is
Michael Lewis who also wrote Moneyball
liars poker and the Big Short and
Michael Lewis joins us now welcome to
the news hour
yes so you focus much of the story on
this New York financial trader who
starts out thinking the markets are all
about one thing discovers that there's
something wrong and basically goes about
trying to change everything yes why did
you focus on him because I was working
on something else and I needed to learn
what high-frequency trading was I mean
this is a term of art it really didn't
even exist until three or four years ago
and it was my ignorance was deep on the
subject and I asked big investors if
they could point me in the direction of
someone who knew about this and they
said there's this young man he's
Canadian who's basically running around
Wall Street explaining this to us and he
knows more about these markets than
anybody and he and so you ought to go
see him and I went to see him just
really on background to see his name is
Brad katsuyama to see what he could
teach me about this and it turned out
that he was engaged in this essentially
attempt to reform Wall Street from
within that to kind of discover what was
wrong with the stock market how
predatory activity had arisen in the
stock market that he had been on the
wrong end of and then educating American
investors about about what was happening
coming in at number four is beating the
street by Peter Lynch
[Music]
in 1990
Peter Lynch retired as manager of
fidelity Magellan the nation's largest
stock mutual fund and one of the most
successful in 13 years
he drove Magellan to a 2800 percent gain
quite simply Lynch has been recognized
as one of the greatest money managers
ever he beat the stock market for so
long not by timing the market but by
picking the right stocks of course no
one can promise you Peter's record but
you can learn a lot from him and you
don't need a billion dollar portfolio to
follow his rules hi my name is Peter
Lynch for 13 years I managed fidelity
Magellan fund those are 13 amazing years
nine times the market declined by 10
percent or more and I was very
consistent all nine times Magellan fund
fell 10 percent or more I learned a lot
of lessons I think they're true now I
think they were true 20 years ago
I think they'll be true 20 years from
now I think I can help you do a better
job of investing coming in number five
is thinking Grow Rich by Napoleon Hill
[Music]
my search led me to the study of the
spiritual forces with which all of us
are blessed and it was in this field and
I came upon a clue which has enabled me
to help millions of people to find their
earthly destinies I want to describe my
discovery in the simplest terms possible
because it will reveal to you why it is
true that's whatever the mind can
conceive and believe the mind can
achieve regardless of how many times you
may have failed in the past or how lofty
or aims and hopes may be mr. Carnegie
delivered a lecture that I shall never
forget because it changed my entire life
and paved the way for my helping to
change the lives of millions of people
some of them not yet born let me call
your attention to a great power which is
under your controls at mr. Carnegie a
power which is greater than poverty
greater than the lack of education
greater than all of your fears and
superstitions combined it is the power
to take the station of your own mind and
direct it to whatever ends you may
desire this profound power mr. Carnegie
continued is the gift of the creator and
it must have been considered the
greatest of all of his gifts to man
because it is the only thing over which
man has the complete unchallengeable
right of control and direction when you
speak of your poverty and lack of
education mr. Carnegie explained you are
simply directing your mind power to
attract these undesirable circumstances
because it is true that whatever your
mind feeds upon your mind attracts to
you now you see why it is important that
you recognize that all success begins
with definiteness of purpose with a
clear picture in your mind of precisely
what you want from life thank you guys
so much for watching I hope you enjoyed
the video I'd love to know how many of
these books have you actually read how
many of them are in your library is
there a 6 7 8 that you want to add to
the list as well that believe nation
other people watch this video need to
read leave it down in the comments below
really curious to hear your thoughts
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon